bonjour Mme Obama et merci beaucoup
d'avoir accordé cette interview à brute à
l'occasion de la sortie de votre livre
en France chez Lumière onu publié par
Flamarion dans les toutes premières pages du
livre vous avez expliqué que ce livre n'est pas
un tuto  manuel que vous n'avez pas de
formule magique et que vous ne prétendez pas
avoir toutes les réponses et je pense que
vos lecteurs seront surpris de
découvrir que vous êtes en proie à de nombreuses
angoisses de nombreux doutes et vous nous montrez
la femme derrière l'icône  et je dois
dire que j'ai été très soulagé de voir que
vous aussi pouvez vous mettre en colère
avec vos enfants et passer une nuit entière à
vous demander si vous êtes assez bon alors je
voulais savoir si vous pensez que l'
autonomisation est aussi une question de partage  nos
peurs et le partage de nos faiblesses en
nous libérant de ce désir de
perfection qui nous anime absolument je
pense
que euh c'est le poinçon d'authenticité
et de vulnérabilité d'autant plus qu'on
s'adresse à des jeunes qui sont
l  en nous regardant,
euh parfois, il est facile de se sentir
comme un modèle, votre travail consiste à
avoir toutes les réponses pour ne montrer aucune
faiblesse, mais je pense que cela
fixe une barre impossible
à atteindre pour ceux qui vous regardent.
En fait, ce n'est pas vrai, nous
luttons tous contre la peur, nous traversons
tous des épisodes de dépression.
moi l'admettant
euh c'est c'est un c'est un code source à
mon pouvoir c'est vous savez être capable de
souligner ma différence et de la
posséder et de réécrire une histoire histoire de pourquoi
ces différences que la différence avait
a fait de moi qui je suis plutôt  que d'essayer
de cacher cela ou de porter un masque de
prétendre que je suis parfait alors que la
perfection n'est jamais le but, donc je pense
qu'il incombe à nous tous qui avons une
plate-forme d'être honnêtes autant
que possible sur le  défis auxquels
nous sommes confrontés et comment nous les surmontons et vous
vous étiez j  Je parle de modèle
et vous savez qu'en France cette notion
de modèle n'est pas aussi populaire qu'aux
États-Unis, mais dans la réalité, beaucoup de
gens ici ont peu ou pas de modèles
auxquels s'identifier et la vérité est aussi que
nous n'en avons pas.  Je ne mesure pas assez ce que c'est que d'être
parfois le seul dans la pièce, alors
pourquoi pensez-vous qu'il est important d'avoir un
modèle et pourquoi est-il aussi si important de
reconsidérer qui sont les héros qu'il est
difficile d'Envision être quelque chose que
vous ne faites pas
Je ne vois pas et peut-être que c'est quelque chose qui est perdu pour les gens qui prennent pour acquis que leur image fait partie de la norme euh il y a des gens qui ont la chance de se voir partout sur les couvertures des magazines à la télévision je ne sais pas  ce que
ça fait parce que je suis une femme noire je suis
grande euh il y a tellement de choses sur
moi qui ne se reflètent pas dans la
culture moderne donc je ne peux pas imaginer ce que ça fait
quand tu te vois mais quand
tu ne le fais pas
euh il y a un ça ça ça ça  ça pèse
sur votre psychisme
euh ça vous donne l'impression que d'une manière ou d'une autre votre
histoire n'a pas d'importance
euh et je pense que cela fait partie de ce qui
crée une certitude incertaine je pense
lentement mais sûrement plus d'entre nous se sentent
malheureusement marginalisés nous nous
sentons invisibles nous avons l'impression qu'il n'y a pas
ce n'est pas une voie claire à suivre pour nous parce que nous n'avons pas de
modèles de rôle
euh je pense que ceux d'entre nous qui ne sont que
des personnes différentes dans la
pièce, il nous incombe d'y venir
avec nous-mêmes pour réécrire
le  histoire de ne pas avoir d'importance et de le
façonner à notre image pour que les gens
comprennent c'est à quoi ressemble une grande femme noire
c'est ce
qui la maintient en vie c'est ce qui la maintient en vie parce que vous
ne savez jamais qui vous allez toucher
qui va  voir que quelle petite fille
va lever les yeux et partir ah je me vois je
sais que je peux arriver à cet endroit parce que
quelqu'un comme moi l'a déjà fait,
donc je pense que nous ne pouvons pas tenir pour acquis l'
importance d'élargir le spectre de
qui compte dont  histoire  s sont importants
et dans ce livre tu sembles très préoccupé
par la jeune génération très souvent
tu t'adresses à cette jeune génération
et tu sembles préoccupé aussi par les
conséquences sur le kovid sur cette jeune
génération une génération qui souffre
de solitude et de dépression et d'
anxiété beaucoup  d'entre eux ont perdu confiance en nous
et ils ont perdu confiance en l'avenir
comment pouvons-nous résoudre ce problème et pensez-vous
qu'il sera possible pour eux d'avoir
confortablement peur comme vous le dites dans le
livre ah ouais je m'inquiète pour cette
génération à
cause de ça
période prolongée de perte et d'
isolement à la suite de la quarantaine,
ils vivent quelque chose qu'aucun
d'entre nous n'a jamais vécu de notre
vivant, nous n'avons donc aucune idée de ce que
seront les résultats à la suite de cet
isolement prolongé, vous associez cela
au fait  que cette génération contrairement à la
mienne contrairement à la
nôtre est très dépendante des médias sociaux
euh ils sont devenus de plus en plus
habitués à développer des
relations au fil des ans  r un téléphone
euh ils se sont habitués à la technologie qui en
dépend d'une manière que je n'ai pas
euh il y a de bonnes choses qui viennent
des médias sociaux mais nous ne savons pas non plus quelles sont
ces conséquences combien cela doit
jouer dans ces  des
niveaux d'isolement et d'anxiété sans précédent que
ces jeunes ressentent, nous avons donc
affaire à beaucoup d'inconnus,
mais ce que je sais, c'est que les
enfants ne sont pas différents de nous, ils
ont soif d'être vus,
ils veulent savoir que  quelqu'un
reconnaît qui ils sont et que comme je
parle dans le livre est le dans le
chapitre que j'appelle commencer genre
euh que nous devons comprendre que les
mots que nous exprimons aux
enfants dans nos vies comptent
nous devons les saluer  avec un niveau de
joie et d'assez parce
que souvent c'est là que commence leur estime de soi,
cela commence par les
interactions qu'ils ont avec les adultes dans leur
vie, c'est pourquoi en tant que première dame à la
Maison Blanche, j'ai passé tant de temps avec des
enfants  dren parce que je savais dans mon cœur que de
nombreux enfants de toute leur vie
ne s'étaient pas sentis vus, alors ouvrir les portes de
la Maison Blanche me donner une voix
, c'était partager ma lumière avec eux afin
qu'ils aient quelque chose à quoi s'accrocher
comme  ils ont relevé les défis
qui se présenteront inévitablement à leur rencontre,
qu'il s'agisse d'une pandémie, d'une
économie en retard ou d'une perte de déception, nous
devons les ancrer avec un sens de la
détermination et nous devons leur montrer
dans chaque interaction que nous les voyons
et moi  pense que c'est essentiel à leur euh
développement continu et à leur capacité
à devenir tout ce qu'ils peuvent être et en
fait, en parlant de solitude, j'ai été
très ému par votre chapitre sur l'
amitié, vous parlez de l'importance de l'
amitié dans votre vie d'
étudiant en tant que jeune mère  et avocat et en
tant que première dame aussi et à quel point
il est important pour vous de réunir autour de
la table de la cuisine des personnes d'
horizons différents de différentes générations, mais vous
semblez  inquiet qu'en tant que culture, nous soyons
tombés en panne avec le développement de l'
amitié, pouvez-vous élaborer sur cela et
pouvez-vous expliquer quel est ce concept de
la table de cuisine bien je euh euh je suis
surpris par le nombre de premiers lecteurs
de ce livre qui affinent  dans ce chapitre
parce que beaucoup d'entre elles disent qu'elles n'ont pas d'
amis et pourquoi parce que je parle généralement
à des femmes occupées des
femmes qui ont donné la priorité à tout
autre qu'elles-mêmes elles ont des
carrières fabuleuses elles sont des mères d'hélicoptère
elles maintiennent leurs familles ensemble et
si nous ne donnons pas la priorité à l'amitié, ce que
je pense à beaucoup de femmes en particulier,
bien que je ne pense pas que ce soit unique
aux femmes, alors c'est alors vous que vous
recherchez un jour et vous n'avez pas beaucoup de ma
communauté de soutien
de ce soutien vient d'
autres femmes a été un outil essentiel
pour moi
euh c'est un tel que je le décris ma
table de cuisine j'utilise cette métaphore
parce que dans ma maison qui grandit du
côté sud de Chicago la table de cuisine
wa  C'est l'endroit où tout le monde s'est réuni dans
le petit petit appartement qui se trouvait sur
Euclid Avenue, c'est là que nous avons résolu
tous nos problèmes pendant que ma mère préparait le
dîner, c'est là que tous mes amis sont venus
pendant la pause déjeuner pour parler
des malheurs de la journée.  un espace où
vous vous sentiez comme si vous pouviez enlever votre
masque et être pleinement vous-même et vous pouviez
être vu et entendu et donc pour moi avoir une
table comme ça un endroit sûr où aller où les
gens où vous pouvez partager vos
expériences où vous pouvez laisser tomber  votre
garde où vous pouvez être levé à nouveau
et et et récupérer des blessures
du monde le le le vous savez les
les combats du jour vous pouvez venir
déposer vos armes et juste être
c'est essentiel et je pense que si  nous ne donnons
pas la priorité à l'amitié aussi
triviale que cela puisse paraître aux gens peut
-être même aux gens qui écoutent qu'est-ce qu'une
amitié vous savez si vous avez une belle
carrière et que vous gagnez un salaire ah
plus tard pour des amis bien je pense
que  à nous ne pouvons pas tenir la
communauté pour acquise et nous
ne pouvons pas sortir de la pratique d'être
intentionnel non seulement de se faire des
amis, mais de les maintenir sur de longues
périodes et je parle de ce que
je passerais dans une éducation  chapitre entier
parlant de la façon dont ma table a été une
ressource pour moi au cours de ces années ouais
absolument et c'est un très beau
chapitre et je vais poser une question
qui je pense que beaucoup de gens vous posent
c'est à propos de cette devise cette expression
que vous  utiliser sur la scène de la convention à
Philadelphie en 2016 quand ils vont bas nous
allons haut c'est un appel bien sûr à la
dignité et au courage mais aujourd'hui les écologistes
et les activités féministes croyaient
qu'on ne pouvait plus attendre et ils
croient que face à l'urgence
peut-être qu'on  doit utiliser des méthodes plus radicales voire
violentes alors comment continuer à se
battre et à se battre dignement alors
que les droits des femmes et les droits des minorités sont
menacés par des Mensonges par manipulation et
par des manipulations très indignes  méthodes c'est l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles dans le livre s'est concentré
sur ce chapitre cette question de savoir
ce que signifie monter haut parce que
je pense qu'après l'avoir dit au stade de la
convention, c'est devenu un slogan
presque une devise que les gens mettent
Des t-shirts et des tasses à café et ils l'ont
répété encore et encore, mais ce qui
manquait, c'était de comprendre qu'une
devise, un slogan ne signifie rien sans
action,
um aller haut ne signifie pas être complaisant,
cela ne signifie pas ignorer les
problèmes urgents  que nous sommes confrontés à accepter l'
injustice et à rester les bras croisés et à être
dignes dans le processus
pour moi, aller haut, c'est transformer cette
rage en action, des plans d'action avec une
stratégie claire doivent suivre la
devise, ils doivent suivre les
mots  Je cite John Lewis, notre défunt
membre du Congrès, qui dit que la liberté n'est
pas un état, c'est un acte, ce n'est pas Un
jardin enchanté sur la colline où
finalement nous allons nous asseoir et nous reposer, cela
nous oblige à travailler et à travailler intelligemment et
à  être stratégique sur nos plans c'est
ce qu'était le mouvement des droits civiques
nous parlons de la marche sur
Washington mais la marche sur Washington
n'était que la cerise sur le dimanche du
changement il y avait des plans pour changer les lois
il y avait des plans il y avait des boycotts
qui ont duré  ans ans
euh et donc ce que j'exhorte la jeune
génération à faire, c'est de réfléchir à des plans
qui ne vont pas seulement naître
de Rage mais qui vont en fait
conduire à changer
euh quand je pense à aller haut, je pense
suis-je  parler à mon émotion la plus brute ou est-ce que
je dis la vérité qui conduira à
un changement réel c'est cette
approche à long terme le résultat final
de mon action cela ouvrira-t-il l'esprit des gens les
amènera-t-il à mieux me comprendre
ou cela conduira-t-il simplement  qu'ils me craignent
plus,
euh, donc j'aborde cela en
détail et parle de la façon dont vous connaissez
la génération d'aujourd'hui, comme toutes les
générations, ils regardent les générations passées et
ils disent que je n'aurais pas fait de cette
façon  peut-être que c'était trop lent combien de temps attendons-nous à
quel point devenons-nous radicaux mais à la
fin je pense que l'intégrité la dignité la
patience la détermination et la planification sont
la clé qui ne devient
jamais démodée et vous dites aussi
que l'écriture est  une façon d'aller haut
et c'est ton deuxième livre en deux ans
et toi tu es un excellent conteur
et tu penses que c'est aussi pour toi
une façon de remettre en question ces vieux récits
des États-Unis et d'essayer de raconter
une autre histoire oui  et et oui,
je pense que plus nous racontons une histoire plus large
de ce que signifie être américain,
plus nous sommes nombreux à avoir la plate-forme pour réécrire comme
je l'ai dit plus tôt l'histoire de ne pas avoir d'importance,
mieux nous sommes à une époque où les
gens  où ce que nous disons et dont les
histoires sont racontées quelle histoire est
mémorisée devient un élément important, nous nous
battons bec et ongles dans ce pays
pour savoir dont l'histoire est racontée et comment quelle
histoire compte qui affecte l'avenir
ce que la prochaine génération comprend le
contexte dans lequel nous avançons, donc
chaque fois que j'ai l'occasion de
passer du temps à disséquer vraiment mes
propres pensées et expériences personnelles et à
ajouter cela au mélange offrant cela
comme point de conversation,
j'essaie de recommencer autant que possible comme
vous avez commencé  en disant que je ne
crois pas avoir toutes les réponses et que ce
livre n'est pas destiné à être qu'il s'agit d'un
aperçu de ma boîte à outils comme je le dis et je
veux que ce soit le début d'une
série de conversations sur ce que
signifie aller  haut comment pouvons-nous
euh faire des changements de manière productive dans notre
pays comment restons-nous vigilants
euh mais mais euh efficaces dans le travail que
nous faisons comment pouvons-nous surmonter notre peur comment pouvons-
nous euh gérer les sentiments d'invisibilité
et de perte
euh tout ça  est une offre
euh et donc ce que je veux que les gens fassent, c'est
mettre leurs outils sur la table également
, voyons comment nous sommes résilients avec
quoi nous travaillons déjà combien de
temps cela vous prend-il pour arriver au point
où vous savez  vous-même assez bien pour
sachez ce qui fonctionne pour vous et ce que vous
devez changer
euh c'est ce que je propose dans ce livre
merci beaucoup Mme Obama pour cette
conversation donc votre livre a dit
merci beaucoup merci encore
merci au revoir prenez soin de vous merci